if my goal was just to be famous which i
don't want then i would be all in on
tick tock but here's a different way of
thinking about it when i'm going to
search for the new iphone comes out
where do i go look for that video i go
to youtube.com and i type in the youtube
search box
that is where i want to live for those
people who are searching for that
information if that answer ever changes
if it's like the new phone came out let
me go into tick tock and see what people
are saying about the phone then i guess
that is when i'll feel that pressure but
i think for the people who feel the
pressure to be relevant or the pressure
for the eyeballs or the fame or
something like that then you'll feel the
pressure because tick tock is 100
accomplishing that now the most viewed
piece of content i have ever made in 15
years is a 12 second tick tock of me
unfolding the lg wing that's 35 million
views if i wanted the eyeballs i'd be
all over tick-tock but i'm trying to
make valuable content for them
and so that's still youtube